the cartel is becoming Filthy Rich
transporting people and drugs into our
country drugs to poison our people and
and massive numbers of people to cause
the border patrol
to dedicate their resources to
processing
people hello I'm Jim Chilton I am an
fifth generation Arizona rancher in
araka Arizona my ancestors drove cattle
from Texas Arizona in
is a very serious issue how many
terrorists are coming
through how many pounds of drugs are
coming through in these areas while the
border patrol is diverted to
lukeville it's very remote
and it's much drier than our Ranch
bottom line they have a wall at
lukeville but people are cutting holes
in it we need the border patrol enough
border patrol to be near the
spots the cartels have made it a
crossing that's effective for for them
now they move people to different areas
people who pay the cartel
$10,000 or 15 or
25,000 they have no choice the cartel
directs them to where the go where they
should go and one of the reasons the
cartel switches locations is it causes
uh border patrol to have to go to those
location at the same time then the
cartel is running drugs and bad people
cross in other areas so in a sense it's
a method of
controlling where everybody goes it's a
method for opening up other routes for
crossing a really bad bad guys drug
Packers we've had ms-13s here at the
ranch we
know that uh there have been about
3,50 people walking through our Ranch so
I think it's a diversionary tactic the
cartels
have I am really concerned about the
terrorist
issue I've been predicting that this is
a national sec security issue it's an
issue
whereby terrorists could come into our
country it's an issue where these
terrorists could at some point in time
like in Israel uh pounce upon uh this
country it only took 19
people to take down the World Trade
Center what would terce do if you had
several hundred several thousand in this
country